soit les la vie à mac os comme ça de
faire genre à l'école des filles
préparent les lunch pour le lendemain
l'enseignante a quatre enfants dont
trois d'un scolaire antenne qui ramène
jusqu'à dose suffit qui est en 5e année
a été la première à être confinées à la
maison pendant deux semaines quand un
copain dans le bus scolaire a été
déclaré positif
basta plat parce qu'à défaut n'avait
rien à faire parce quelqu'un hors
réunion travail était fini
on avait rien à faire on ne peut prouver
on est est moi j'étais seul je l'appris
pas de talent les deux parents de sophie
enseigne ils ont pris quelques jours de
congé en alternance mais pas durant
toute sa quarantaine une graine ne
voulait pas épuisé tous ses congés dès
septembre ni trop pénaliser ses élèves
de troisième année
moi ce que j'aimerais ça être davantage
le pour eux
en même temps je partage et parce que
j'en ai eu 18 est en maintenance qui
attendent après moi aussi donc on est
toujours un peu déchiré
honnêtement moi je trouve ça très du
seul alexis qui est en 2e secondaire
vient tout juste de vivre deux semaines
d'enseignement à distance loin qu'une
6ème de se concentrer pendant quinze
jours une réunion que en vrai si tavel
profs devant toi et j'avais de la misère
à comprendre qu'il fallait que je
reprenne des cours trente ans moi je
mets ça comme mode jeune enseignant
temps de pandémie est une montagne russe
de stress et d'émotion
les apprentissages sont plus ardue
ingrid grain que les échecs de ses
élèves grimpe en flèche
c'est un stress qui est assez énorme et
être capable de gérer ça avec la famille
en même temps je dirais que
c'est là que la fatigue embarque le
plusieurs enseignantes que sont à bout
de souffle les signes précurseurs de
l'hiver ne trompent pas
les journées raccourcissent il fait déjà
presque nuit quand marie galant rentre
de l'école avec son fils
[Musique]
l'année elle est déjà la maison son
école est fermée pour deux semaines
sinon je suis pas des yeux comme je vais
penser au début mais c'est sûr que c'est
moins fun et être sa raison parce que ça
te dérange non parce que j'aime bien
cuisiner j'aime bien faire que ça me
dérange pas que le dimanche soir vers
18h 19h on apprend nous les familles
quelle école ferme et qu'il faut ça
regrette barre dès le lendemain sur viré
de bord et tout un casse-tête pour une
mère monoparentale coupé de son réseau
sont plus jeune a été peaufiné en
septembre j'étais paul quentin cossez
j'aimais quand même l'école mais aussi
non quand j'ai cherché reste à mener 62
ans j'ai peur qu'on doit rapidement
préparer notre suppléance préparer notre
groupe quitter notre classe en urgence
on doit ces agités vraiment dernière
minute
et malheureusement peut pas compter sur
l'aide de la famille par exemple les
grands parents parce que eux ils font
partie des des en plus fragile
marie s'est débrouillé avec une amie
enseignante qui est aussi une mère
monoparentale leurs garçons qui sont
dans la même classe de 4e année au fait
l'écho la distance ensemble on a pris
chacune quelques journées de congé pour
prendre nos deux garçons qui étaient
bons qu'ils étaient 105 temps il y a des
milliers d'enseignants parents au québec
beaucourt déjà épuisé leurs six jours de
congés de maladie le programme fédéral
de relance économique permet de prendre
une dizaine d'autres congés à une
fraction de leur soleil je ne crois pas
que tu arrêtes suffisent à simon année
continue de cette façon la tester c'est
la classe de mon enfant ferme à
plusieurs après la classe de mon autre
enfin refaire aussi on y arrivera paul
on n'arrivera pas monétairement depuis
le confinement la motivation scolaire
est beaucoup moins comme peu
d'enseignants ont les moyens de prendre
des congés sans solde beaucoup d'enfants
restent seuls à la maison quand leur
classe est fermée pour mama
beaucoup plus stressé parce qu'elle perd
quand même son groupe et demandant c'est
plus de mandat alors et sa joie mais et
elle est toujours est un porno les mêmes
quand ils sont à la maison
les enseignants en moins de temps ça
fait qu'ils peuvent être moins le format
comme en a besoin parce qu'ils ont
besoin de faire du télétravail et puis
deux fois comme ça sans déborder les
enfants n'ont néanmoins teint là avec
nous fait il n'y a plus de travail
j'adore mes enfants j'adore mes élèves
j'ai je me sens un peu déchiré notre
seul pour apaiser le stress ingrid a
repris la peinture 20 seulement des
femmes des femmes qui à force de se
tenir la tête en or de laure on peut
pour sauver votre avant les difficultés
finissent par avoir un très long cou oui
je me sens comme ça
probablement comme tous les ans au
québec